Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Buying has never been more convenient in America today. If you're in a major metro area, you can have just about anything you want delivered right to your door within minutes or hours. Clothes, groceries, fast food medicine, you don't even need to leave the house. Yet at the same time, some Americans are moving toward a different path, decluttering their homes and lives, and adhering to lifestyles like minimalism and financial independence retire early, also known as fire. Why do some people buy so much while others shun that lifestyle for simplicity or to save?
欢迎收听美国心理学会的双周播客《心理学谈话》，我是主持人凯特琳·卢娜。如今在美国，购物从未如此便捷。如果你身处大都市区，几乎任何你想要的东西都能在几分钟或几小时内送到家门口。衣服、杂货、快餐、药品，你甚至不需要走出家门。然而与此同时，一些美国人正走向另一条道路，他们清理自己的家和生活，坚持极简主义和“财务独立，提前退休”（即FIRE）等生活方式。为什么有些人买个不停，而另一些人却为了追求简约或储蓄而避开这种生活方式？
How do brands reach into our psyches to get us to pull out our wallets at credit cards? What are some of the motivations behind companies that try to appeal to our sense of social responsibility to get us to spend? Our guest for this episode is psychologist Dr. Kit Yarrow, an expert on consulting. Behavior and Professor Emerita at Golden Gate University in San Francisco. She studies why and how people shop and buy and how companies can best meet consumer needs. She's the author of Decoding the New Consumer Mind about the motivations and behaviors of shoppers today and Jen Buy about the consumption habits of millennials. Dr. Yarrow is regularly interviewed on national media, including Good Morning America, NPR and USA Today. Welcome, Dr. Yarrow. It's a pleasure to have you.
品牌是如何深入我们的心理，让我们掏出钱包和信用卡的？那些试图利用我们的社会责任感来促使我们消费的公司，其背后的动机是什么？本期节目的嘉宾是心理学家基特·亚罗博士，她是消费者行为咨询专家，也是旧金山金门大学的荣誉退休教授。她研究人们为何购物、如何购物，以及公司如何最好地满足消费者需求。她是《解码新消费者思维》（关于当今购物者的动机和行为）和《千禧一代的消费习惯》（关于千禧一代的消费习惯）的作者。亚罗博士经常接受《早安美国》、美国国家公共电台（NPR）和《今日美国》等国家级媒体的采访。欢迎您，亚罗博士。很高兴能邀请到您。
Thank you. I'm excited to be here. Today's consumers, as I said, can get almost anything they want whenever they want. What is motivating consumer spending today? Well, you know, in some ways, it's the same as it's always been that people need things and obviously. And shopping helps people prep for life transitions, like thinking about having a baby or moving and so on. And we just simply crave newness. So those are fairly constant. But I think what's different today is the triggers. So never before, and I've been studying this for more than 20 years, have I seen people so attracted to bargains. So I think this fear of missing out, which we call FOMO in my field, is really motivating to shoppers. And it's detrimental, I think, to their financial help, that people get more excited about the bargain than they do about what it is they're actually buying. The same kind of trigger of FOMO applies when you're on vacation. And so it's like, I have to get this here and now, otherwise I won't be able to get it later or limited time off or limited quantity available.
谢谢。很高兴来到这里。正如我所说，今天的消费者可以随时随地获得他们想要的几乎任何东西。是什么在激励着当今的消费者支出？嗯，你知道，在某些方面，这和过去一样，人们有需求，这是显而易见的。购物有助于人们为生活转变做准备，比如考虑生孩子或搬家等等。而且我们只是单纯地渴望新鲜感。所以这些是相当恒定的。但我认为今天不同的是触发因素。所以，我研究这个领域已经超过20年了，我从未见过人们对廉价商品如此着迷。所以我认为，我们领域所说的“错失恐惧症”（FOMO）确实在激励着购物者。而且我认为这对他们的财务健康是有害的，人们对廉价商品的兴奋程度超过了对他们实际购买的东西本身的兴奋程度。同样的FOMO触发因素也适用于度假时。所以感觉就像是，我必须此时此地买下它，否则以后就买不到了，或者因为限时优惠或库存有限。
So these are the triggers, I think, that are a little bit different today than in the past. In terms of some of the products that people are buying today that are relatively new, what I'm finding is that anxiety reducing products are so big. today. So this is one of the big shifts as well that CBD, sleep aids, blue ray glasses, a lot of these things to me just point out that we're an increasingly anxious society and people are gravitating towards whatever they think is going to help them fix their anxiety, heavy blankets and so forth. And the other thing people are looking for that's a little bit different than in the past is products that help or brands that help them feel. connected to other people. So we've seen this big uprising in wanting to do business with companies
所以我认为，这些是今天与过去略有不同的触发因素。就人们今天购买的一些相对较新的产品而言，我发现缓解焦虑的产品非常受欢迎。所以这也是一大转变，大麻二酚（CBD）、助眠产品、防蓝光眼镜，对我来说，很多这类东西都表明我们是一个日益焦虑的社会，人们倾向于任何他们认为能帮助他们解决焦虑的东西，比如重力毯等等。人们正在寻找的另一件与过去略有不同的事情是，能够帮助他们或品牌能够帮助他们感到与他人建立联系的产品。所以我们看到了这种想要与符合你价值观的公司做生意的巨大兴起，我们称之为“目的营销”。我认为这在很大程度上与人们的一种孤独感有关，他们想要感到与他人有联系，他们想要体验，而不仅仅是拥有物品。是的，正如你提到的，许多品牌正在超越传统的广告，承担起社会事业。我想到的几个著名例子是多芬（Dove）挑战审美刻板印象的活动。我们还有吉列（Gillette）今年早些时候挑战“有毒男子气概”的活动。汉堡王（Burger King）最近推出了“真实餐点”（Real Meals）活动，鼓励人们感受自己的情绪，并知道“感觉不好也没关系”。你认为这些活动是否比以往任何时候都更能引起消费者的共鸣并转化为销售额？
that match your values, we call it purpose marketing. And a lot of this is really related to, I think, a sense of kind of loneliness that people have, that they want to feel connected to other people and they want to have experiences instead of just things. Yeah, just as you mentioned, many brands are going beyond that traditional advertising to take on social causes. And a few notable examples that come to mind are dove with its campaigns about challenging beauty stereotypes. We have the Gillette campaign that challenged toxic masculinity that was from earlier this year. And Burger King recently came out with its Real Meals campaign that encourages people to feel their emotions and know that it's okay not to be okay. Do you think those campaigns resonate with
这取决于它们做得有多好。例如，你提到的吉列活动，你知道，那个活动的目的是让人们知道，男人可以做得更好。实际上，人们对那个活动感到愤怒。他们觉得吉列，一个大公司，在教我如何做父母。我不这么认为。而像多芬和REI（户外用品零售商）的一些活动则引起了共鸣。
consumers and translate into sales more than ever before? It depends on how well they're done. So, for example, the Gillette campaign that you mentioned, you know, the purpose of that campaign was to let people know that, you know, men can do better. And really, people bristled at that one. They felt like Gillette, you know, a big company is telling me how to be a parent. I don't think so. Whereas others like Dove and REIs had some campaigns that have resonated.
耐克（Nike）也有引起共鸣的活动。你知道，这取决于它们在消费者眼中感觉有多真实。有时它们实际上并没有那么真实。比如耐克在宣扬女性权益的同时，这家公司本身却面临着女性提起的性别歧视诉讼。你知道，这种讽刺，只是因为他们的活动在消费者看来感觉非常真实。它感觉如此真诚，以至于它奏效了。因为我认为今天的消费者，他们总体上不信任商业。
Nike's had campaigns that have resonated. You know, it depends on how authentic they feel to the consumer. Sometimes they're not actually all that content, authentic. Like Nike's championing of women at the same time that this very company, you know, has class discrimination suits against them by women. You know, the irony of that, it's just that their campaign feels so authentic to consumers. It feels so genuine that it works. Because I think consumers today, they don't trust business in general.
所以他们寻找的是对公司价值观的深入了解。如果一家公司非常擅长真诚地传达价值观，我认为多芬和REI就是这种情况，或者他们是非常优秀的营销人员，比如耐克，虽然可能并不真诚，但在消费者看来却是这样。这让他们感觉良好。人们不想仅仅购买产品，他们想在某种意义上购买与公司的联系，即他们得到的不仅仅是一个产品，品牌今天必须超越利润作为存在的理由。看起来人们确实想要，普通消费者想要更多地与品牌保持一致。
So what they are looking for is a peak inside the values of the company. And if a company is really good at either genuinely communicating values, which I think is the case with Dove and REI, or they're really good marketers like Nike, and it may not be genuine, but it looks that way to consumers. This feels good to them. People don't want to just buy products. they want to buy a connection to the company in a sense that they're getting more than a product, that brands have to kind of go beyond profit as a reason for existing today. It does seem like people want to, general consumers, want to align themselves more with brands.
我听过人们这么说。比如他们想使用某种产品，可能是因为它环保、更健康、非转基因等等。这似乎是你经常听到的事情。我不能说这是否比过去更多，但品牌确实似乎想要更多地进入每个人今天所持有的价值观。是的，这绝对是真的。我的意思是，毫无疑问，我认为部分原因是我们的产品太多了，竞争非常激烈。而且因为我认为人们没有通过一些旧的传统方式建立联系，比如通过宗教或社区，了解周围的人，你知道，我认为有一种人们想要归属感，想要与超越他们生活中存在的事物建立联系的感觉。所以品牌可以扮演这个角色，品牌让人们觉得他们得到的不仅仅是产品。所以毫无疑问，如果你可以从四个不同的地方购买西红柿，其中一个是当地种植的，你觉得你在支持一个实际的个人，他们没有使用化学物质，他们正在为学校做出贡献等等，你会购买那些西红柿，而不是你认为是大规模生产的西红柿。所以，很多时候消费者确实在做出伟大的决定，帮助他们的社区，帮助他们的星球，帮助一切变得更好。
I've heard people say that. Like they want to use a certain product maybe because it's environmentally friendly or it's healthier or non-GMO or something like that. It seems like that is something you do. you hear more often. I can't say if that's more so than in the past, but it does seem like brands want to get more into the values each person holds today. Yeah, it's definitely true. I mean, without a doubt, I think partly because we have so many products, competition is huge. And because I think people aren't connected through some of the old traditional ways that they connected through either religion or their community, knowing people around them, you know, there's a sense of, I think,
有时我不得不说，他们被操纵了，那些标榜这些全天然特性的产品，对环境并没有更好，对个人也没有更好。他们只是把这作为他们的展示。对消费者来说信息量太大了。坦率地说，没有人有时间去评估所有这些。所以一方面，我认为我们有机会，老话说“用你的钱包投票”，通过你购买的东西来宣扬你的价值观。另一方面，这也是一个被营销人员操纵的全新机会。我想在稍后谈谈其中一些营销技巧。但我确实想提到一些你在第一个回答中谈到的关于购买体验的事情。
people wanting to belong to things and wanting to connect to higher values beyond, you know, just what exists in their life. And so brands can play this role and brands make people feel like they're getting more than just products. And so without a doubt, if you can buy, you know, tomatoes from four different places and, you know, one of them is a locally grown, you feel like you're supporting a, you know, an actual individual and they aren't using chemicals and they're contributing to schools and so forth, you're going to buy those tomatoes instead of what, you know, you perceive to be mass-produced tomatoes. So, you know, a lot of times consumers are really making great decisions that help their communities, help their planet, help, you know, everything better.
所以人们正如你所说，更愿意投资于购买一种体验，比如去旅行或看音乐会之类的。那么有更多的人转向这种趋势了吗？是的，绝对是。所以，我们总是被稀缺性所吸引。而今天稀缺的是情感、体验和使命感。而今天丰富的是大规模生产的产品。所以人们过去想要的，用来向他人展示自己是谁，用来连接到更大、更好的事物的东西，往往是一种产品，比如奢侈品或更好的产品或更多的产品。现在那不再稀缺了，现在那让人感到不知所措。
And then sometimes I have to say, you know, they're being manipulated that, you know, that GM, you know, some of the products that tout these all-natural characteristics are really not any better for the environment, not any better for the individual. They're just using that as their showcase. It's just so much information for consumers. And frankly, nobody has time to evaluate all of it. And so on the one hand, I think we have this opportunity to, you know, the old saying is vote with your wallet to, you know, to tout your values through what you buy. And on the other hand, it's a whole new opportunity to be manipulated by marketers. I want to touch on some of those marketing. techniques that work in a bit here. But I do want to mention something, go on something you talked about
我的意思是，我们被产品淹没了。我认为人们正在寻找的是他们从体验中获得的强烈情感。然后是人们从产品中获得的一些好处，即通过你拥有的东西向他人展示你是谁的情感利益，这在历史上一直存在。我的意思是，这并不新鲜。或者，通过产品展示你属于一个特殊的阶层。你知道，那在经济衰退后变得有些俗气，但人们仍然可以通过在社交媒体账户上炫耀他们购买的东西，也就是他们购买的体验来做到这一点。所以你不能确切地把你的新鞋放在社交媒体上说，“看我，我太酷了”，但你可以把你的泰国之旅放在上面。它在某种程度上实现了同样的事情，但感觉并没有那么俗气。是的，社交媒体如何影响购买？嗯，我认为很多人因为社交媒体而做出的购买决定并不总是符合他们的最大利益。例如，我发现当人们不断接触产品时，因为
and your first answer, about buying experiences. So people are more, as you said, invested in buying an experience like going on a trip or a concert or something like that. So are more people moving to that trend? Yeah, definitely. So, you know, we always are attracted to scarcity. And what's scarce today, you know, is emotion and experience and a sense of purpose. And, you know, what's abundant today are mass produced products. So what people used to want, you know, to showcase who they are to other people, to, you know, connect to something more, bigger, better was oftentimes a product, like a luxury product or a better product or more products. And now that that's no longer scarce, now that that's like so overwhelming.
它在他们的社交媒体信息流中，他们会对这些产品产生一种熟悉感，这让他们觉得他们可以拥有它们。这阻止了他们进行理性的决策过程，去思考：我真的想要它吗？我买得起吗？它适合我的生活方式吗？我会用它吗？它只是以一种令人毛骨悚然的侧面方式成为了他们生活的一部分。同样地，我认为当你看到你的朋友拥有特定的产品或进行了改造，他们有这些新的厨房用品，或者无论这些产品是什么，或者豪华假期，这似乎是一种新的同伴压力。我认为社交媒体在购买方面对我们产生负面影响的另一种方式是，我们只有那么多的韧性。所以当我们不断地被某样东西“跟踪”时，也许我们看了一眼，也许我们去了一个网站，我们看到了一个产品，我们考虑了一下，决定不买。好吧，接下来你知道，无论你在网上走到哪里，那个产品都会跟着你。你知道，它只是出现在你的信息流中，或者它作为广告出现在你正在阅读的杂志网站上。所以人们只会说“不”那么多次，然后他们就更有可能屈服。所以所有这些事情，我认为，导致人们做出了如果不是因为我们的在线生活，特别是社交媒体，他们可能不会做的购买。这是人们购买他们不需要的东西的原因之一吗？我的意思是，我相信很多人都买过东西。它现在还放在衣柜里，标签还没拆，积满了灰尘。可能应该捐掉。这就是为什么吗？人们，为什么会发生这种情况？
I mean, we're just bloated with products. I think what people are looking for is the emotional intensity that they get from an experience. And then some of the benefits that people got from products, the emotional benefit of showing other people who you are through what you have, which has been throughout time. I mean, this is not new. Or, you know, showing that you're in a special class of people through a product. You know, that sort of became goche.
是的。所以这是原因之一。这实际上是我在研究中发现的东西，在我去过的所有家庭中，我通常做的是民族志，这意味着我走进人们的房子，我查看他们的衣柜、床底下、冰箱后面，取决于我正在研究的产品或类别。但我突然注意到，哇，不仅仅是我，或者这个女人或那个男人。每个人都有他们没穿过的衣服在衣柜里，或者他们没用过的产品在浴室水槽后面。我想，为什么会这样？所以我把它作为我研究的一个附加部分，一个个人兴趣。我发现这很大程度上与我所说的“错误思维”有关，某人会爱上一件物品。我认为衣服是最容易观察的。所以他们爱上了一件物品，他们真的想拥有它，但它太贵了。然后它打折了，但它没有他们的尺码。所以他们还是买了，心想也许会合适，或者颜色不太对。你知道，所以这是他们想要的产品，但可能是黄色的，而黄色不是他们的颜色。所以他们还是买了。所以它有一点不对劲，但其他一切都
tacky after the recession, but people can still do that by showing off what they buy through their social media accounts, the experiences they buy, I mean. So you can't exactly put your new shoes on social media and say, look at me, I'm so cool, but you can put your trip to Thailand on there. And it kind of accomplishes the same thing, but it doesn't feel quite as tacky. Yeah, and how does social media influence buying? Well, I, I think a lot of people make some buying decisions because of social media that are not always in their best interest. So, for example, I found that when people constantly come in contact with products because
是对的。他们会合理化继续购买它的行为。另一件发生的事情是，人们有一种他们想象的幻想生活。所以，很多人买太小的衣服，认为他们会变瘦。然后，你知道，发生了什么？他们变瘦了，但他们实际上并不喜欢他们瘦下来后挑选的东西。他们想，那个瘦下来的自己想挑选自己的东西，或者它不合适，或者他们从来没有变瘦，或者他们想象他们会去游轮旅行或发生不会发生的事情。所以他们有衣服来匹配他们现在实际上没有的生活，然后它没有发生。我发现人们购买他们最终没有穿的东西的另一个原因是，这听起来很傻，但我一遍又一遍地听到。他们太爱它了。他们害怕它会发生什么。所以他们就像在“珍藏”它。他们存了又存，存了又存，它就放在那里，他们正在等待合适的场合。而且有某种原因，任何场合都不够好。他们可能会弄洒。合适的人不会看到他们穿它，等等等等。他们实际上并没有穿这些东西，因为他们太爱它们了。最后一个原因，非常普遍，特别是现在我们在网上购物，醉酒购物或吸食大麻后购物。所以我有一些我最喜欢的消费者故事，是人们买了非常离谱的东西。然后他们
it's in their social media feed, they develop this sense of familiarity with those products that makes them feel like they can have them. And it stops them from going through the rational decision-making process of wondering, do I really want it? Can I afford it? Does it fit into my lifestyle? I'm going to use it. It's just sort of becomes part of their life in a kind of like creepy sideways kind of way. And by the same token, what also happens is I think when you see your friends have particular products or have remodeled and they have these new kitchen things or, you know, whatever these products are or fancy vacations, it seems like it's a new kind of peer pressure, I think. Another way,
说，看，这就是当你吸食大麻后购物时会发生的事情。所以我在所有这些方面的建议是，不要买任何你不能退货的东西。而且，你知道，那会解决很多问题。是的，如果你受到影响，或者即使没有，最好远离手机，远离亚马逊的一键下单。也许有点睡眠不足，无论那可能是什么。是的。那么，公司试图利用哪些基本的人类冲动和不安全感来让我们购买？我知道我们谈到了焦虑，但你认为营销人员还会关注哪些，并说，好吧，让我们试着通过这种或那种方式吸引人们来销售我们的产品？你知道，我认为廉价商品确实是公司所依赖的。这是他们的，这也是他们的阿喀琉斯之踵，因为当他们试图以折扣价销售所有东西时，他们的利润率会降低。但它对消费者有效，这就是他们这样做的原因。所以很多商店实际上在货架上摆满了他们从未真正预期会以全价出售的商品，因为他们知道消费者会在降价时购买。所以，对我来说，消费者等待廉价商品或受到廉价商品的启发是有道理的。
I think social media affects us negatively in terms of purchasing is that, you know, we only have so much resilience. So when we're constantly stalked by something, maybe we looked at, you know, maybe we went to a website and we saw a product and we thought about it, decided not to. Well, the next thing you know, wherever you go online, that product follows you around. You know, it just pops up in your feed or it pops up as an ad on a, you know, magazine site that you're reading. And so people will say no, only so many times, and then they're more likely to cave in. So all of these things, I think, contribute to people making purchases that maybe they wouldn't have made were it not for our online lives and very specifically also social media. Is that one of the reasons why people buy things
我认为我们不相信我们能从本质上理解产品的价值。所以我们依靠价格来告诉我们是否得到了划算的交易，或者我们是否被宰了，而且我认为我们也直觉地理解，当它打折时，它可能不会持续太久，所以它激励我们立即采取行动。但最终，我发现人们确实花了太多时间去思考那个价格，而他们没有在思考产品本身。在一个理想的世界里，我希望看到消费者只看产品，甚至不看价格，决定他们是否喜欢它，
they don't need? I mean, I'm sure many people out there have bought something. It's now still sitting in the closet with the tags on, collecting dust. Probably should be donated. Is that why? people, why this happens? Yeah. So it's one of the reasons. This is actually something I found in my research was that in all the homes I go to, so what I usually do is in ethnography, which means that I go in people's houses and I look in their closets and under their beds and the backs of their freezers and, you know, depending on the product I'm researching or the category I'm researching. But all of a sudden I noticed like, wow, it's not just me or this woman or that guy. It's freaking everybody that has clothes they haven't worn in their closets or products they haven't used in the back
然后看价格。你知道，我认为人们最终会得到更多他们喜欢的、真正让他们满意的产品，这样他们最终会花更少的钱，购买更少的产品。人们购买的许多产品，你知道，他们不喜欢，他们最终没有使用，它们不令人满意，它们不能带来快感，所以他们最终购买更多。我认为如果我们能更仔细地检查产品，并认真思考我们想在生活中增加什么，我们就能解决这个问题。我认为我们今天看到的营销人员使用的其他技巧，可能在10年前不太流行，就是“重塑”的概念。所以我们对技术的使用，我认为让我们真正热爱创新和
of their sinks under in the back of their bathroom sinks. And I thought, you know, why is that? So I kind of made that like an added part of my research, a personal interest. And I found that a lot of it has to do with what I call faulty thinking, that somebody will fall in love with an item. Clothing is the easiest, I think, to look at. So they fall in love with an item and they you know, really want to have it, but it's too expensive. And then it goes on sale, but it didn't go on sale in their size. So they buy it anyway, kind of thinking maybe it will, or it's not quite their right color. You know, so it's the product they wanted, but it's like maybe yellow and yellow's not their color. So they buy it anyway. So it has like one thing wrong with it, but everything else is
新鲜感。所以当我们认为某样东西被“重塑”时，我们就会对它感到非常兴奋。而且你知道，我们想了解更多关于它的信息。所以，特别是在网上，特别是在社交媒体上，我们了解到了重塑的鞋子、重塑的珠宝、汽车、胸罩等等。坦率地说，这些产品中有很多并没有被重塑。分销系统被重塑了，或者也许它的一个方面被重塑了，或者有更多的透明度，但这不一定是产品优势。所以消费者对这种他们可能在支持一家小型、新公司的想法感到非常兴奋，
right with it. And they kind of, you know, rationalize going ahead and buying it. Another thing that happens is that people sort of have this fantasy life that they're imagining. So, you know, a lot of people buy clothes that are too small for them thinking that they're going to get thinner. And then, you know, what happens is they get thinner and they don't actually like what their skinny self picked out. They want to, you know, that skinny self wants to pick out their own things, you know, or it didn't fit or they never do get slim or, you know, they imagine like they're going to be going on cruises or things that don't happen. So they have clothing to match a life that they don't actually have now and then it doesn't happen. And another reason that I found that people buy things they don't
但这可能不是对他们最好的产品。这可能不是对他们正确的选择。当然，很多时候，价格也不是最好的。但他们上当了。同样，部分原因是社交媒体的东西，你知道，它跟踪他们等等，但部分原因我认为我们真的被它被“重塑”的整个概念所迷惑了。然后也许还有一点是我们如何支付东西。所以我们与我们正在赚取并放弃以支付某样东西的实际金钱的联系越少，
actually end up wearing is because, and this is going to sound really silly, but I heard this over and over again. They love it so much. They're afraid something will happen to it. So they're like saving it. They save and save and save and save and it just sits there and they're waiting for just the right occasion. And there's some reason why any occasion isn't good enough. They could spill. The right people aren't going to see them in it and on and on and on. And they don't actually wear these things because they love them too much. Last reason, incredibly common, especially now that we're shopping online, drunk shopping or high shopping. So I have some of my favorite consumer stories are people that bought like very outrageous things. And then they
我们就越容易过度消费，甚至可能陷入债务。所以如果每个人都真正思考他们必须工作多少小时才能获得这个特定的产品，或者他们正在放弃什么，你知道，如果我得到这个，哦，那是我正在考虑的假期的十分之一，或者，哦，天哪，我必须工作八个小时才能得到那么多钱来支付那个。所以我认为如果我们更清楚我们为购买的东西所做的交换，我们会购买更好的东西，而且可能更少的东西。所以，你知道，你怎么做到这一点？嗯，我认为每次我们使用简便支付，你知道，信用卡已经加载在电脑里了。所以我们只需要按一个按钮。这给了我们更少的时间来真正做出那些，
go, see, this is what happens when you shop when you're high. And so my advice in all of these is don't buy anything you can't return. And, you know, that'll solve a lot of problems. Yeah, it's better to stay away from the phone, the Amazon one click away if you've been under the influence or not. Maybe a little sleep deprived, whatever that might be. Yeah. So what are some of those basic human impulses and insecurities that companies try to appeal to
去产生那些想法，比如，哦，天哪，你知道，如果我得到那个，我就不能得到这个，或者，哦，伙计，那是一大笔钱，你知道，我只有这些钱。你知道，这就是我们真正想做的，思考那次购买对我们的财务健康和安全，以及我们可能想要和需要的其他东西的影响。你认为这意味着人们因为网上购物而花得更多吗？嗯，我们确实看到信用卡债务再次上升。我的意思是，这部分是因为银行正在放宽他们的要求。
to get us to buy. I know we've talked about anxiety, but what others do you think marketers look at and say, okay, let's try to sell our product by appealing to people in this way or that way? You know, I think the bargain thing is really what companies rely on. It's their, and it's their Achilles heel too, because their margins are decreased when they try to sell everything on sale anyway. But it works with consumers, and that's why they do it. So a lot of, a lot of, stores actually stock their shelves with merchandise that they never really anticipate they'll sell for full price, knowing that consumers will buy it when it's reduced. So, you know, it makes sense to me that consumers wait for bargains or they're inspired by
我们在经济衰退后看到它很好地下降了。有一段时间，经济学家们有点认为，哦，看看我们。我们都表现得这么好。但这可能是因为我们无法获得任何信贷。但总的来说，我们确实看到债务水平再次上升，这可能表明人们更容易花钱。而且我们绝对看到人们更容易在网上购买产品。但人们购物的方式有两种不同的方式。我不认为，我不认为实体店——讨厌那个词。你知道，实体零售，我不认为那会消失。
bargains. I think we don't trust that we understand the value of a product inherently. And so we rely on price to tell us if we're getting a good deal or if we're getting ripped off or, you know, and we also, I think, intuitively kind of understand that when it's on sale, it probably won't last as long, so it motivates us to take action immediately. But in the end, what I find is that people really spend way too much time kind of thinking about that price and they aren't thinking about the product. In an ideal world, what I'd love to see is consumers just look at the product, not even look at the price, decide if they like it or not,
我认为，你知道，两者都有陷阱。人们确实喜欢在两个领域购物，原因不同。你更有可能在实体店还是网上冲动消费？我认为你在两者中冲动消费的几率相当。在网上，让人们冲动消费的事情是其他，你知道，它做得太好了。当网站让你挑选你的产品，它进入你的篮子，然后弹出“其他购物者也看了这个”，你就会得到新的想法。或者，你知道，如果你也买这个，那么你可以获得免费送货。你知道，我们的送货门槛是
and then look at the price. You know, and I think people would end up with more products that they enjoy that are actually really satisfying to them so that they ultimately spend less money and buy fewer products. A lot of the products that people buy, you know, they don't like, they don't end up using, they're not satisfying, they don't get a thrill from, and so they end up buying more. And we can solve that problem, I think, if people are really much more careful about examining the product and thinking hard about what they want to add to their life. The other kind of tricks, I think, that we see marketers using today that maybe were less popular 10 years ago is this concept of something being reinvented. So our use of technology, I think, has made us really love innovation and
X金额。天哪，人们为了获得免费送货或免费优惠花了很多钱。所以，你知道，如果你在化妆品上花了100美元，那么你就可以免费得到这袋化妆品。然后，你知道，很多时候人们会购买他们不需要的东西。而且大多数时候，那些都是冲动购买。附加购买也是如此。就像在商店里一样，我发现如果人们还没有做出购买任何东西的承诺，他们更善于分析他们正在考虑购买的产品。一旦他们做出购买某样东西的承诺，他们就完全敞开了犯错的大门。所以这就是为什么，你知道，经典的例子是杂货店收银台的糖果。但是，你知道，所有的商店都考虑过人们
newness. And so when we think that something's been reinvented, we get all excited about it. And you know, we want to learn more about it. So, you know, especially online and especially in social media, we learn about reinvented shoes and reinvented jewelry and car. and bras and you name it. And frankly, a lot of these products are not reinvented. The distribution system is reinvented, or maybe one aspect of it is reinvented, or there's more transparency, but it's not necessarily a product benefit. So consumers get very excited about this idea that they're supporting maybe a small,
在商店结账排队时会看到什么，并且知道他们正在销售大量商品。当人们做出购买承诺时，他们知道他们要拿出钱包、信用卡等等，现在他们愿意购买更多。网上也是一样，一旦人们做出购买承诺，他们就愿意购买更多。所以总的来说，我会说，你知道，好的购物方式是让消费者再次退后一步，重新评估他们正在考虑购买的每一件产品，并警惕附加购买。那是冲动购买中最危险的，就是附加购买。我们如何抵制它？
new company, but it may not be the best product for them. It may not be the right choice for them. Certainly, a lot of times, is not the best price. but they fall for it. And again, partly because of the social media stuff, you know, that it stalks them and so on, but partly because I think we really fall for the whole concept of it being reinvented. And then maybe one other is how we pay for things. So the more detached we are from actual money that we're earning that we're giving up to pay for something,
因为当你排队时，总是会发生这种情况，你知道，比如在Bed Bath and Beyond，你正排队穿过。那里有所有这些你不需要的小东西，但哦，也许我确实需要那个。或者有糖果。或者你说，你知道，又有你的定向广告了。如果你在网上搜索过某样东西，你去任何网站，你都会再次看到它。你如何抵制它而不上当？我的意思是，当然，我们知道，好吧，我不应该把钱花在那上面。
the easier it is for us to overspend and even potentially go. go into debt. So if everybody really thought about how many hours they had to work in order to get this particular product or what they're giving up, you know, if I get this, oh, that's one-tenth of a vacation I was thinking of, or, oh, geez, I had to work eight hours in order to get that much money to pay for that. So I think if we were much more aware of the exchanges we're making for things that we buy, we would buy better things and probably fewer things. So, you know, how do you do that? Well, I think every time we use easy payment, you know, the credit card is already loaded in the computer. So we just have to press a button. This gives us fewer seconds to actually make those,
我不需要这个额外的东西，但这很难。这是一个检查手机邮件或拿起手机上未读完的小说的好时机。所以，你知道，对于技术给我们带来的所有消费方面的负面影响。也许其中一个积极因素是一点点分心。但对于绝对所有的事情，你知道，人们能做的最好的事情就是列出他们想要在生活中增加的东西，并了解原因，不要偏离那个清单。这意味着，你知道，你甚至不会考虑那些在结账排队时的东西，因为它们不是
to have those thoughts of, oh, geez, you know, if I get that, I won't be able to get this or, oh, man, that's a big chunk of change, you know, and I only have this money. You know, and that's what we really want to do is think about the impact of that purchase on our financial health and security and, you know, and other things that we might want to buy and need. Do you think that means people are spending more because of online shopping? Well, we are seeing credit card debt go back up again. I mean, that's partly because banks are loosening up their requirements.
你事先确定的那天购买的一部分。这听起来很严厉，比如，哦，你不能享受只是添加一些口红之类的乐趣。我的意思是，为什么不呢？而且，你知道，总的来说，因为我认为如果你购买的是你着手购买并考虑过的东西，你会比你只是后来扔进去的东西更喜欢那个产品。这些经常发生。而且这在我的研究中得到了证实。嗯，你知道，当我与人们谈论他们从什么中获得快乐，以及他们的钱花在哪里最值得时，从来没有提到过那是他们在最后扔进去的东西。没有。所以这些不是令人满意和满足的购买。所以我说，你知道，在你的脑海中明确你要
We saw it dip really nicely after the recession. And for a while, their economists were kind of. of thinking, oh, look at us. We're all being so well behaved. But it might have been that we couldn't get any credit. But in general, we are seeing debt levels rise again, which probably indicates that people are spending money more easily. And we definitely are seeing people shop for products more easily online. But there's kind of like two different kinds of ways that people shop. I don't think, I don't think brick and mortar hate that term. You know, physical retail, I don't think that's going away.
着手购买什么，并坚持下去。这是一个好主意。这就是为什么我们听到人们说，比如，你知道，我去塔吉特（Target）买两样东西，结果花了100美元。这种情况在好市多（Costco）总是发生在我身上。我会看我的账单。我想，哦，天哪。是的。我的意思是，通常是我确实需要的东西，但这有点令人震惊。有时你走进去，哦，我只是去买些杂货，结果我带走了一个淋浴架，一些新毛巾。哦，天哪。是的，我想我们几乎所有人都经历过这种情况。你知道，其中一些，很有趣，你提到了塔吉特和好市多，因为一些零售商确实赢得了我们的信任，以至于它们实际上是我们允许自己更开放的地方。可能比任何其他地方都多的是好市多，但塔吉特，我也从
I think there's, you know, there's pitfalls to both. And people do enjoy shopping in both arenas for different reasons. Are you more likely to impulse buy in person or online? I think you impulse buy pretty equally in both. Online, the thing that gets people to impulse buy is other, you know, it's just so well done. When websites you pick out your product, it goes in. your basket and then up comes. Other shoppers also looked at this and you get new ideas. Or, you know, if you buy this one too, then you can get free shipping. You know, our shipping threshold is
消费者那里听说，我们允许自己有点，你知道，对他们提供的产品感到好奇。我们正在尝试产品。你知道，我们被介绍给新事物。我们得到新的想法。这些商店涵盖了我们的整个生活方式，从我们穿的到我们吃的。所以，你知道，有很多可能性。所以老实说，我从消费者那里收到的关于在那些特定商店做出的糟糕购买决定的投诉，并不像他们在百货公司，例如，或在亚马逊，或，你知道，另一种类型的零售商那里那么多。所以，尽管如此，人们确实会犯错。我听到最多的是他们买得太多了。所以他们在好市多，他们说，好吧，你知道，那只是
X amount. And oh my gosh, people spend a lot of money to get free shipping or a free offer. So, you know, if you spend $100 on cosmetics, then you get this bag of cosmetics for free. And then, you know, a lot of times people will buy things they don't need. And most of the time, those are kind of impulse purchases. And so are the add-on purchases. Just like in stores, what I found is that if people haven't made a commitment to buy anything, they're much better at analyzing the products they're considering buying. Once they make a commitment to buy something, they're just wide open to making mistakes. So that's why, you know, the classic example is the candy at the register at the grocery store. But, you know, in all stores have thought about what people
$5，你知道，是我们会在普通杂货店花的两倍。多划算。所以他们购买的数量比他们实际会使用的要多得多，你知道，或者最坏的情况，他们购买了更多对他们不好的产品，比如饼干，然后他们确实吃了。所以这有点像，嗯，我总是喜欢看到人们使用数学。所以，但他们有点在计算，他们用两倍的钱得到了三倍的东西。他们上当了。同样，这是廉价商品，每次都能抓住人们。你知道，而且危险在于他们不使用它，或者他们使用了它，而他们可能不应该使用。但我认为采样也
will see in the checkout line in stores and know that they're selling a lot of merchandise. As people have made a commitment to buy, they know they're going to get out their wallet, their credit card, whatever, and now they're open to buying more. And the same thing happens online that once people make a commitment to buy, they're open to buying more. So in general, I would say, you know, good shopping would be for consumers, again, to kind of pull back and reevaluate every single product they're considering buying and to be wary of the add-on buy. That's the most dangerous impulse buy is the add-on buy. How do we resist that?
创造了一种义务感。所以当有人给你东西时，你觉得你应该真正考虑它，而也许，你知道，软糖维生素并没有在你的清单上，但因为你拿了一个，你尝了它，味道不错，而且你可以，你知道，维生素有什么错，你最终买了它。所以你得到了新的想法，然后你得到了这种义务感，而且价格点通常很好。所以，你知道，再次，我认为人们必须尽可能尝试坚持他们的清单。我认为有几个地方，人们在偏离清单时不会遇到那么多麻烦。也许那是其中的几个。那是我们刚才谈到的实体店可能会使用的技巧之一吗？
Because that always happens when you're at the line, you know, say of like a bed bath and beyond and you're sneaking through the line. There's all these little things you don't need, but oh, maybe I do need that. Or there's candy. or you said, you know, there's your served ads again. If you've searched for something online, any website you go to, you see it again. How do you resist that and not fall for? I mean, of course, we know, okay, I shouldn't be spending the money on that.
他说样品。你知道，这确实让你觉得，哦，也许我应该买那个，因为这个好心人给了我这个。是的。是的，样品绝对有效。哦，天哪。而且，你知道，即使是采样，任何形式的义务感。所以你可能已经注意到，在现在的许多百货公司，人们会问你在购物时是否想要一些水。这让你觉得，仅仅那一杯水就让你觉得更开放，更乐于购买。而且我认为对于许多消费者来说，客户服务太糟糕了，当他们去购物时，他们感到被虐待，如果他们只是被对待，
I don't need this extra thing, but it's hard. This is a really good time to check your email on your phone or pick up your novel where you left off on your phone. So, you know, for all the negatives in terms of consumption that technology has brought to us. Maybe one of the positives is a little bit of a distraction. But with absolutely everything, you know, the best thing people can do is make a list of what it is that they want to add to their life and understand why and not deviate from that list. So that means that you're, you know, you're not going to even consider things that are, you know, in the checkout line because they're not
很好，他们想买点东西，只是为了投票支持那家商店。所以，你知道，我们的互惠社会规范，你知道，有时，我的意思是，在某些方面这是一件美妙的事情，而在其他方面，你知道，它可能会让你花钱，并且要意识到，你知道，那杯水附带了一点价格标签，即使它是免费的。而在另一方面，我假设因为这种情况发生了，所以当广告一次又一次地投放给你，你再次看到这个产品时，它是有效的。这是否被证明是有效的，能让人们随后进行购买？嗯，所以广告中有一种规则，人们在第一次不会听到或看到广告。
something that you determine beforehand. We're going to be part of your purchasing that day. It sounds really harsh, like, oh, you can't have fun of just adding in, like, some lipstick or something. I mean, why not? And, you know, generally speaking, because I think you're going to enjoy that product more if it's something you set out to buy and considered than if you just throw it in later. These are so often. And this is, like, really proven in my research. Well, you know, when I talk to people about what they get pleasure from and, you know, where their dollars were most well spent, never does it come up that it was the thing they threw in at the end. It doesn't. So these are not satisfying and gratifying purchases. And so I say, you know, to have in your mind what it is that you
是你事先决定好的。我们那天会参与你的购买过程。这听起来很苛刻，好像是说，哦，你不能享受随手加购一支口红之类的乐趣。我的意思是，为什么不呢？你知道，总的来说，因为我认为如果你买的是你计划好并考虑过的东西，你会比随手加购的东西更享受那个产品。这种情况太常见了。这在我的研究中得到了充分证明。嗯，你知道，当我与人们谈论他们从什么中获得快乐，以及他们的钱花在哪里最值得时，从来没有提到过他们最后随手加购的东西。从来没有。所以这些并不是令人满意和愉悦的购买。所以我说，你知道，要在心里明确你
are setting out to buy and stick to it. That's a great idea. Is this why we hear people say, like, you know, I went to Target to buy two things and I spent $100. That happens to me all the time at Costco. I'll look at my bill. I'm like, oh, my gosh. Yeah. I mean, it's usually things I do need, but it's sort of shocking. Sometimes you walk in there like, oh, I'm just going to get some groceries and I walk away with like a shower caddy, some new towels. Oh, boy. Yeah, I think pretty much all of us have been in that boat before. You know, some of it, it's funny, you mentioned Target and Costco, because some retailers have so earned our trust that they actually are places where we do allow ourselves to be more open. Probably more than any other place is Costco, but Target, I hear also from
打算买什么，并坚持下去。那是个好主意。这就是为什么我们听到人们说，你知道，我去塔吉特百货只打算买两样东西，结果却花了100美元吗？我在开市客也经常遇到这种情况。我看着账单，心想，天哪。是的。我的意思是，通常确实是我需要的东西，但这有点令人震惊。有时你走进去，心想，哦，我只是去买点杂货，结果却带走了一个淋浴挂篮和一些新毛巾。天哪。是的，我想我们几乎所有人都经历过这种情况。你知道，这很有趣，你提到了塔吉特和开市客，因为一些零售商已经赢得了我们的信任，以至于它们确实成了我们允许自己更开放的地方。可能比任何其他地方都更甚的是开市客，但塔吉特，我也从
consumers that we kind of allow ourselves to be a little bit, you know, curious about what they have to offer. We're sampling products. You know, we're introduced to new things. We get new ideas. The stores cover our entire lifestyle from, you know, our lives, everything from what we wear to what we eat. And so, you know, there's a lot of possibilities. So honestly, I don't get as many complaints from consumers about bad purchase decisions made in those particular stores as I do when they're in a department store, for example, or on Amazon or, you know, another different type of retailer. So, but nevertheless, people do make, people do make mistakes. And the ones that I hear about the most are that they buy too much. So they're at Costco and they say, well, you know, that's only
消费者那里听说，我们确实允许自己对他们提供的商品保持一点好奇心。我们在试用产品。你知道，我们接触到了新事物。我们有了新想法。这些商店涵盖了我们生活的方方面面，从我们穿的到我们吃的。所以，你知道，有很多可能性。所以老实说，我从消费者那里听到的关于在这些特定商店做出糟糕购买决定的抱怨，并没有像在百货公司、亚马逊或其他不同类型的零售商那里听到的那么多。但是，尽管如此，人们确实会犯错。我听到最多的是他们买得太多了。所以他们在开市客，他们说，嗯，你知道，那只要
$5 for, you know, twice as much as we would spend to get, you know, at a regular grocery store. What a deal. And so they buy much more, a much higher quantity of a product than they will actually use, you know, or worst case scenario, they buy a lot more of a product that's not good for them, like cookies and then they do use it. So there's something about like, well, I'd like to see, I always like to see people using math. So, but they're kind of calculating that they're getting three times as much for only twice as much in dollars. And they fall for that. Again, it's the bargain thing that gets people every time. You know, and the, and the danger there is that they don't use it or that they use it and they probably shouldn't. But I think also sampling.
5美元，就能买到我们在普通杂货店花两倍价格才能买到的两倍数量。多划算啊。于是他们买得更多，买的数量远超他们实际会使用的量，你知道，或者最坏的情况是，他们买了很多对他们没好处的产品，比如饼干，然后他们确实吃了。所以这有点像，嗯，我喜欢看到人们使用数学。所以，他们计算出他们用两倍的钱买到了三倍的东西。他们上当了。再一次，这就是让人们每次都中招的“便宜货”心理。你知道，危险在于他们不使用它，或者他们使用了本不该使用的东西。但我认为试用也
creates a sense of obligation. So when somebody gives you something, you feel like you should really consider it, whereas maybe, you know, gummy vitamins were sort of not on your list, but because you got one, you tasted it, tasted good, and you could, you know, what's wrong with vitamins, you end up buying it. So you get new ideas and then you get this sense of obligation and then the price point's usually good. And so, you know, again, I think just people have to try to stick to their list as much as possible. There are a few places, I think, where people don't get into quite as much trouble deviating from their list. And maybe those are a couple of them. Is that one of those techniques we were just talking about that a physical store might use?
创造了一种义务感。所以当有人给你东西时，你会觉得你应该认真考虑一下，而也许，你知道，软糖维生素并不在你的购物清单上，但因为你拿了一个，你尝了尝，味道不错，而且你可以，你知道，维生素有什么坏处呢，你最终还是买了它。所以你得到了新想法，然后你产生了一种义务感，而且价格通常也不错。所以，你知道，再一次，我认为人们必须尽量坚持他们的购物清单。我认为有几个地方，人们在偏离清单时不会遇到那么多麻烦。也许那几个地方就是其中之一。这是我们刚才谈到的实体店可能会使用的一种技巧吗？
He said samples. You know, it does make you feel like, oh, maybe I should buy that because this nice person gave me this. Yeah. Yeah, samples definitely work. Oh, my goodness. And, you know, even sampling like any sort of sense of obligation. So you might have noticed that in a lot of department store now, people ask you if you'd like some water when you're shopping. And that makes you feel, just that one water makes you feel much more open and receptive to buying. And I think for a lot of consumers, customer service is so bad and they feel so mistreated when they go shopping, that if they're just treated,
他说的是样品。你知道，这确实让你觉得，哦，也许我应该买那个，因为这个好心人给了我这个。是的。是的，样品确实有效。天哪。而且，你知道，即使是试用，也会产生任何形式的义务感。所以你可能已经注意到，现在很多百货公司，当你购物时，店员会问你是否需要喝水。这让你感觉，仅仅那杯水就让你感觉更开放、更乐于购买。而且我认为对于很多消费者来说，客户服务太糟糕了，他们在购物时感到被虐待，所以如果他们被对待得
nicely, they want to buy something just to kind of like vote in favor of that store. So, you know, our social norms of, you know, reciprocity, you know, sometimes, I mean, in some ways it's a wonderful thing and in other ways, you know, it can cost you money and to just be aware of it that, you know, that that water comes with a little bit of a price tag attached to it, even if it's free. And on the flip side of that, I'm assuming because this happens that it's, does work when ads are served to you again and again and you see this product again. Does is that proven to, to work to get people to then make a purchase? Well, so there's kind of like a rule in advertising that people don't hear or see an ad the first
很好，他们想买点东西，只是为了给那家店投上一票。所以，你知道，我们的互惠社会规范，你知道，有时，我的意思是，在某些方面这是一件美妙的事情，但在其他方面，你知道，它可能会让你花钱，只要意识到这一点，你知道，那杯水其实是带有一定代价的，即使它是免费的。反过来说，我假设因为这种情况确实发生了，所以当广告一次又一次地展示给你，你再次看到这个产品时，它是有效的。这是否被证明确实能促使人们进行购买？嗯，广告界有一种规则，人们不会在第一次听到或看到广告时就...
time. It takes like a few times, like at least three times before people generally like get the gist of what you're selling. But if you see it over and over and over again, probably they didn't have enough advertisers because, yeah, what we found over and over and over again on TV, I'm talking about. Okay. Because generally what has happened there is that they didn't get enough variety of advertisers and, you know, they're just bonusing those spots to their advertiser that they do have. And consumers actually find that incredibly annoying and it backfires.
时间。通常需要几次，至少三次，人们才会大致明白你在推销什么。但如果你反复看到它，那可能是因为他们的广告商不够多，因为我们在电视上反复发现的情况就是这样。因为通常发生的情况是，他们没有获得足够多样的广告商，你知道，他们只是把这些广告位作为赠品送给了现有的广告商。而消费者实际上觉得这非常烦人，反而适得其反。
It is very annoying when you see the same thing again. You're like, I've watched this commercial forever. horrible. Yeah, it is. Are we more influenced by people we don't know like celebrities or, you know, strangers who would review something on Amazon or people who do product reviews on YouTube? Are those people more influential to us than, say, a family member or a friend in terms of buying? No, no, for sure, the family members and friends are number one. They have been for all time. They probably will be for all time. So as somebody that you actually know in trust is, number one. But number two are people you perceive to be like you. So that's why reviews on
当你反复看到同样的东西时，确实非常烦人。你会觉得，这个广告我看了一辈子了，太糟糕了。是的，确实如此。我们更容易受到我们不认识的人的影响，比如名人，或者在亚马逊上评论某样东西的陌生人，还是那些在YouTube上做产品评论的人？在购买方面，这些人比我们的家人或朋友更有影响力吗？不，不，当然，家人和朋友是第一位的。他们一直以来都是，将来也可能一直都是。所以，你真正认识并信任的人是第一位的。但第二位是你认为和你相似的人。这就是为什么在网站上的评论……
websites where they break down age, for example, or, you know, skin tone if you're looking at cosmetics or where people live, you know, you see that you can filter out the reviewer according to other criteria. This makes those reviews much more credible. Now, so we're looking, so first of to answer your question, family and friends come first, and then people we perceive to be like us, everybody else has fallen off. So when people do trust barometers, what we found is trust in government, trust in businesses, trust in even NGOs, nonprofit organizations, really trust across the board has diminished for consumers. Consumers feel really burdened by having to figure out everything themselves because they don't trust these social establishments that are there supposedly to serve them.
比如按年龄分类，或者如果你在看化妆品，按肤色分类，或者按人们居住的地方分类，你知道，你会看到你可以根据其他标准筛选评论者。这使得这些评论更加可信。所以，回答你的问题，首先是家人和朋友，然后是我们认为和我们相似的人，其他所有人都排在后面。因此，当人们进行信任度调查时，我们发现消费者对政府、企业，甚至非政府组织、非营利组织的信任，实际上各方面的信任度都在下降。消费者感到非常负担，因为他们必须自己弄清楚一切，因为他们不信任这些本应为他们服务的社会机构。
And they're looking for trustworthy sources of information because really who can possibly do all the research, right? So enter now the Instagrammer, the YouTuber, the blogger that appears to be like them and appears to have like great deep knowledge of a particular subject matter, whether it's home improvement or makeup or something like that. And those people become in a way kind of like a friend or family member. You know, you can develop a level of intimacy or a feeling of intimacy with them that allows their recommendations to carry almost as much weight as somebody that you actually know. So I think what we're finding, though, in the review world is that, you know, this is so new.
他们正在寻找值得信赖的信息来源，因为说实话，谁能做完所有的研究呢，对吧？所以现在出现了Instagram网红、YouTube博主、博主，他们看起来和他们很像，并且似乎对某个特定主题有很深厚的知识，无论是家居装修还是化妆等等。这些人以某种方式变得像朋友或家人一样。你知道，你可以与他们建立一种亲密感或亲密的感觉，这使得他们的推荐几乎和你真正认识的人一样有分量。所以我认为，我们在评论界发现的是，这太新了。
I mean, when you think about it, it's really a new field. And now the system is being games so much. So many of the reviews on Amazon are not authentic and on other websites. And so consumers are learning that they can't always trust the reviews anymore. And they're discovering ways of trying to figure out who's authentic and who's not, like verified purchasers and so forth. And what are some of the shopping and money mistakes you see people? off and make. I think we've touched on a few, but can you elaborate on that a little more?
我的意思是，当你想到这一点时，这确实是一个新领域。现在这个系统被操纵得太厉害了。亚马逊和其他网站上的许多评论都不是真实的。因此，消费者正在学习他们不能再总是相信评论了。他们正在发现试图弄清楚谁是真实的，谁不是的方法，比如已验证的购买者等等。你认为人们常犯的一些购物和金钱错误是什么？我想我们已经谈到了一些，但你能详细说明一下吗？
Well, first and foremost, it's being overly focused on bargains. So not paying enough attention to the product and whether that's the right one for you and really getting way too excited about how much your so-called saving by buying something. The second one, I think, is getting, you know, obsessed with whether or not you're getting a return on your time investment. So this is especially true, I think, when people shop and outlet malls, they'll draw. drive some length of time and they feel like because they spent so much time getting somewhere, well, they're just going to have to get something. And the same is true. I think when people are shopping online, if they spend a significant amount of time looking for something, they sort of feel like
嗯，首先也是最重要的，是过度关注便宜货。所以没有足够关注产品本身，以及它是否适合你，并且真的对你通过购买某样东西所节省的所谓金额感到太兴奋了。我认为第二个错误是，变得沉迷于你是否从时间投资中获得了回报。我认为当人们在奥特莱斯购物时尤其如此，他们会开车行驶一段距离，他们觉得因为他们花了这么多时间才到达那里，好吧，他们就必须买点什么。我认为当人们在线购物时也是如此，如果他们花了大量时间寻找某样东西，他们会觉得……
they have to get something back for that time investment. Not having enough pain of payment, I like to call it. So, you know, I think it's, I think when people can really easily purchase things. This is, this allows them to buy more than they probably should. And maybe the best example there is when people take Uber and Lyft. I found that a lot of shoppers, a lot of the consumers I've spoken with, um, sort of look at it like a free ride, you know, and then the credit card bills comes and they've spent way more than they thought they would on transportation. Because there's, you know, they just get out of the car and they don't have any sort of pain of payment. You know, in general, what we want is people to really carefully analyze all the money that leaves their possession and think about whether or not they're giving up something important by making that purchase or how hard it was to earn money to make that purchase.
他们必须为那段时间的投资得到一些回报。我喜欢称之为缺乏“支付痛苦”。所以，你知道，我认为当人们可以非常容易地购买东西时。这使他们能够购买比他们可能应该购买的更多的东西。也许最好的例子就是人们乘坐Uber和Lyft的时候。我发现我交谈过的很多购物者，很多消费者，有点把它看作是免费乘车，你知道，然后信用卡账单来了，他们花在交通上的钱比他们想象的要多得多。因为，你知道，他们只是下车，没有任何支付的痛苦。你知道，总的来说，我们希望人们真正仔细分析所有离开他们手中的钱，并考虑他们是否通过那次购买放弃了重要的东西，或者赚取那笔钱来进行那次购买有多么困难。
And that doesn't happen as easily when people are being able to just press a button or get out of a car and make a purchase. I think buying more than you need is another mistake that people make. So this could be buying, you know, too big of a quantity at Costco, or it could be, you know, getting that extra color of something when, you know, if it looked good on you in black, then you get it in yellow two and you never wear the yellow one. And then, you know, I find that one of the mistakes that people make very often is they just spend too much money on their kids. You know, I think it's a substitute for spending time with them.
而当人们能够只需按一下按钮或下车就完成购买时，这种情况就不那么容易发生了。我认为购买超过你需要的数量是人们犯的另一个错误。这可能是指在Costco购买了过多的数量，或者可能是指，你知道，买了那种东西的额外颜色，当你，你知道，如果它穿在你身上黑色很好看，然后你又买了黄色的，结果你从来没穿过那件黄色的。然后，你知道，我发现人们经常犯的一个错误是，他们在孩子身上花了太多的钱。你知道，我认为这是花时间陪伴他们的一种替代品。
And there's really nothing that. you can buy a kid that's better than a happy you being debt-free and having time to spend with them. I want to turn now to what I mentioned at the top of the show about people who are on the other side of the coin. So let's say let's start with people who want to declutter their lives, which is really the antithesis of the consumer economy. They want to get rid of things. Why do you think people want to pare down the items they own? Well, I think we're just bloated. I mean, you know, we've had this huge influx of incredibly cheap merchandise coming in a lot from China, a lot. You know, the cost of products today has gone way down.
而且真的没有什么东西是你买给孩子，比一个快乐的你、没有债务、有时间陪伴他们更好的了。我现在想转到我在节目开头提到的关于硬币另一面的人。所以让我们从那些想要精简生活的人开始，这实际上是消费经济的对立面。他们想摆脱东西。你认为为什么人们想要减少他们拥有的物品？嗯，我认为我们只是臃肿了。我的意思是，你知道，我们有大量极其便宜的商品涌入，很多来自中国，很多。你知道，今天产品的成本已经大幅下降了。
And there's great abundance of cheap merchandise, mass-produced merchandise available. And consumers have, you know, stuffed their closets, stuffed their shelves. And it doesn't feel good. We don't feel good. Managing products makes us feel uncomfortable. makes us feel burdened. And so I think this movement towards decluttering and really thinking about the Marie Kondo effect, really thinking about the products that give you pleasure and whether or not you want them in your lives.
而且有大量廉价商品、大规模生产的商品可供选择。消费者已经，你知道，塞满了他们的壁橱，塞满了他们的架子。这感觉并不好。我们感觉不好。管理产品让我们感到不舒服。让我们感到负担。所以我认为这种迈向精简的运动，真正思考近藤麻理惠效应，真正思考那些给你带来快乐的产品，以及你是否想让它们出现在你的生活中。
In concept, this is terrific. We'll make people feel so much better to be very, very conscious about what they would like to have in their life and get rid of the things that they don't want in their life, you know, donate them and so forth. So all this is wonderful. I think it's a terrific movement. I think it absolutely makes sense from the perspective of how bloated most consumers feel and how overpurchased most people are in all income levels, by the way. I'm not just talking about wealthy people here.
从概念上讲，这太棒了。让人们非常、非常清醒地意识到他们想要在生活中拥有什么，并摆脱他们生活中不想要的东西，你知道，捐赠它们等等，这会让人们感觉好多了。所以这一切都很棒。我认为这是一项了不起的运动。我认为从大多数消费者感到多么臃肿以及大多数人在各个收入水平上都过度购买的角度来看，这绝对是有道理的。顺便说一句，我不仅仅是在谈论富人。
The only problem I have is that what I see is that people declutter and that they buy more stuff. So for some consumers, not all, I mean, some people declutter and then they're really pleased with their, you know, more carefree life. I mean, it just feels clean and healthy and it's easier. It takes less time to manage your life when you have fewer things in it. But then I would say there's a good, healthy proportion of people that then sort of fill up those shelves again, almost intuitive, almost instinctively. and that's where the problem arises. So I would say in terms of people who want to declutter their lives on a more extreme end, there's people who consider themselves minimalists.
我唯一的顾虑是，我看到人们精简了，然后他们又买了更多的东西。所以对于一些消费者来说，不是全部，我的意思是，有些人精简了，然后他们对他们，你知道，更无忧无虑的生活感到非常满意。我的意思是，它感觉干净、健康，而且更容易。当你拥有的东西更少时，管理你的生活所需的时间就更少。但我会说，有相当一部分人几乎是直觉地、几乎是本能地又把那些架子填满了。这就是问题所在。所以我认为，就那些想要在更极端的一端精简生活的人来说，有些人认为自己是极简主义者。
So they only own things they need. You know, you hear about people who have only 10 items of clothing. They live in very Spartan living conditions. Why do you think this appeals to people? You know, I think in general what we're seeing through the declutter movement, through the minimalist, through the fire movement, And I think in all of these situations, what we're seeing is a reaction to an unhealthy aspect of our culture. That people, there's a backlash to overconsumption.
所以他们只拥有他们需要的东西。你知道，你听说过那些只有10件衣服的人。他们生活在非常简朴的生活条件下。你认为为什么这吸引人们？你知道，我认为总的来说，我们通过精简运动、通过极简主义者、通过FIRE运动所看到的。我认为在所有这些情况下，我们所看到的是对我们文化中不健康方面的一种反应。人们，这是对过度消费的一种反弹。
People feel like it's bad for our environment. It's bad for our psyches, that it takes up too much of our time. And so in a variety of different ways, people are looking for solutions to that. Like how can they more consciously and live a life where can some, is based on need and not knee jerk or wants. And what about people who are a part of that fire movement, I said? So that's defined as financial independence retire early. So those people are not spending much because maybe they're opting to buy use clothing,
人们觉得这对我们的环境有害。这对我们的心理有害，它占用了我们太多的时间。所以以各种不同的方式，人们正在寻找解决方案。比如他们如何能更自觉地生活，生活在一个消费基于需求而不是膝跳反应或欲望的世界里。那么那些参与我所说的FIRE运动的人呢？所以这被定义为财务独立，提前退休。所以那些人花钱不多，因为也许他们选择购买二手衣服，
ride a bike instead of taking a car and saving most of the money they earn. Is that a popular movement? Is it pervasive enough to be called a movement? And do you think what are some positives and negatives to it? Yeah. I think it is pervasive. enough to be called a movement. And it is really the extreme of the decluttering and the minimalist movement. But in this case, they're also hoping to not have to work. So they have not found
骑自行车而不是开车，并节省他们赚到的大部分钱。这是一个流行的运动吗？它是否普遍到可以被称为一场运动？你认为它有哪些积极和消极的方面？是的。我认为它足够普遍，可以被称为一场运动。它确实是精简和极简主义运动的极端。但在这种情况下，他们也希望不必工作。所以他们没有找到……
satisfaction through employment and they want to be financially independent. And so, you know, part of their decision to decrease their spending and look for alternative ways to get their needs met is, you know, perhaps to declutter, perhaps, you know, to improve the environment, but also because they don't want to have to work. So on the one hand, you know, there are like all these really creative ways to get what you need. I mean, Goodwill and secondhand stores are just bulging. And, you know, you really can, you really can get a lot of what you need without new manufacturing taking place and, you know, borrowing things. This has been a movement like to co-own products or borrow things.
通过就业获得满足感，他们想要财务独立。所以，你知道，他们决定减少支出并寻找替代方式来满足需求的部分原因，你知道，也许是为了精简，也许，你知道，为了改善环境，但也因为他们不想工作。所以一方面，你知道，有所有这些真正创造性的方式来获得你所需要的。我的意思是，Goodwill和二手店简直爆满了。而且，你知道，你真的可以，你真的可以在没有新制造发生的情况下获得你所需要的很多东西，而且，你知道，借用东西。这已经成为一种运动，比如共同拥有产品或借用东西。
There's all these ways that we can consume less and add fewer products to the world. But working in and of itself for a lot of people provides like a tremendous sense of connection to others and a tremendous gratification of having purpose and, you know, an impetus, I think, to create things that a lot of people. I think would feel would be missing. You know, in some of the high wealth individuals I've interviewed, you know, one of their great fears, for example, is that they were to die young and give their kids too much money and an inheritance that they would lose their interest in working, which a lot of people
我们有很多方式可以减少消费，并向世界增加更少的产品。但对很多人来说，工作本身提供了一种与他人巨大的联系感，以及一种拥有目标和，你知道，一种动力，我认为，去创造很多人。我认为会感到缺失的东西。你知道，在我采访过的一些高净值人士中，你知道，他们最大的恐惧之一，例如，是如果他们英年早逝，给他们的孩子太多的钱和遗产，他们会失去工作的兴趣，很多人……
feel like is, you know, a great source of pride and accomplishment and contribution to the community. So, you know, there's pros and cons and tradesoffs. I'm sure plenty of people in the fire movement are finding really productive things to do in their community. And I mean, certainly they've found creative ways to get their needs met. So hopefully their creativity is extending in a way where they feel purposeful and connected to others. Yeah, I've done some research into that area. It seems like a lot of people are saying maybe getting out of that rat race, if you will, and doing work they enjoy.
觉得这，你知道，是自豪感、成就感和对社区贡献的巨大来源。所以，你知道，有利有弊，有权衡。我相信FIRE运动中的很多人在他们的社区中找到了真正富有成效的事情去做。而且我的意思是，当然他们已经找到了创造性的方式来满足他们的需求。所以希望他们的创造力正在以一种让他们感到有目标并与他人联系的方式延伸。是的，我在这方面做了一些研究。似乎很多人都在说，也许摆脱那种竞争，如果你愿意的话，去做他们喜欢的工作。
Also just being free from debt. It seems like a big motivating factor is just to not be, you know, chained down to an expensive mortgage, cars and various things like that. Or, you know, some people do also seem maybe driven by the environmental impact, as you mentioned, too. Yeah. Being free from debt, you know, whether, you know, whether your goal is to not have to work or whether your goal is to just not have a credit card payment, I am all for that. That is such a psychological burden. So one of my mantras, you know, whenever I'm hoping to help consumers buy better, is that there's nothing you can buy, nothing you can own that will make you feel better than not having debt. So, you know, debt is such a burden. And usually the things you're buying are not, you know, equal or better than that debt, which means that you just walk around with a sort of.
还有就是摆脱债务。这似乎是一个很大的激励因素，只是为了不被，你知道，被昂贵的抵押贷款、汽车和各种各样的东西所束缚。或者，你知道，有些人似乎也确实受到环境影响的驱动，正如你提到的那样。是的。摆脱债务，你知道，无论，你知道，你的目标是不必工作，还是你的目标只是没有信用卡账单，我完全支持这一点。那真是一个心理负担。所以我的口头禅之一，你知道，每当我希望帮助消费者更好地购买时，就是没有什么东西是你买得起的，没有什么东西是你拥有的，会让你感觉比没有债务更好。所以，你知道，债务是一个巨大的负担。而且通常你买的东西并不，你知道，等于或好于那个债务，这意味着你只是带着一种……
source of psychological negativity in your life and you would actually be a happier person skipping that purchase and not having that debt. Now that's obviously for discretionary purchases. Some people go into debt for other reasons. But, you know, debt is an emotional burden. And, you know, the less debt you have for, you know, whether or not you, you know, save really hard and pay off your mortgage as quickly as possible, avoid buying a car using a, you know, using debt, but, you know, wait or get a used car or wait until you can afford one to buy it completely. All of these things will make you happier than debt. And how does your work influence your buying behaviors? You know so much.
生活中的心理负面来源，如果你跳过那次购买并且没有那笔债务，你实际上会是一个更快乐的人。现在这显然是针对可自由支配的购买。有些人因为其他原因背负债务。但是，你知道，债务是一种情感负担。而且，你知道，你拥有的债务越少，为了，你知道，无论你是否，你知道，努力储蓄并尽快还清抵押贷款，避免使用，你知道，使用债务买车，但是，你知道，等待或买一辆二手车，或者等到你能负担得起时再完全购买它。所有这些事情都会让你比债务更快乐。你的工作如何影响你的购买行为？你知道得太多了。
Well, you know, I think I got interested in this initially. Like partly because I've always been interested in retail, but partly because I really do. I'm basically cheap at heart. I mean, I'm just cheap. And, you know, I thought it was a fun game when I was younger to figure out how to get more for less. And then ultimately, you know, I enjoyed sharing this with other people. So my mom told me once after I got started actually doing my own research, she said, this is so funny because I remember at the grocery store once we were standing in line and you were looking in the cart ahead and you go,
嗯，你知道，我想我最初对这个感兴趣。部分是因为我一直对零售业感兴趣，但部分是因为我真的确实。我本质上很抠门。我的意思是，我只是抠门。而且，你知道，当我年轻的时候，我想弄清楚如何用更少的钱买到更多的东西是一个有趣的游戏。然后最终，你知道，我喜欢与其他人分享这一点。所以我妈妈在我开始真正做自己的研究后曾经告诉我，她说，这太有趣了，因为我记得在杂货店，有一次我们排队，你看着前面的购物车，你说，
hey mom how come those people have diet soda and cheesecake so kind of a basic little kid question but I think I've always been interested in what people how what people buy says about who they are and what it says about the world that we live in too I'm a pretty I'm not a good example because I'm a pretty cheap person by name not cheap like cheap with my friends but I don't like I never really likes debt I don't I don't even have a mortgage I hate debt I you know I feel cleaner and safer with it. But I like, I appreciate what shopping brings to our life and what product bring to our life. And I just feel like if you analyze where you get the most joy and pleasure and really think about that and not be afraid to spend money where, you know, it's meaningful to you,
嘿妈妈，为什么那些人有健怡汽水和芝士蛋糕？所以这算是一个基本的小孩问题，但我认为我一直对人们买什么，以及它如何说明他们是谁，以及它说明了我们生活的世界感兴趣。我是一个相当……我不是一个好的例子，因为我是一个相当抠门的人，不是那种抠门，不是对我的朋友抠门，但我不想……我从来没有真正喜欢过债务，我甚至没有抵押贷款，我讨厌债务，我，你知道，我觉得有它更干净、更安全。但我喜欢，我欣赏购物给我们的生活带来的东西，以及产品给我们的生活带来的东西。我只是觉得如果你分析你在哪里获得最多的快乐和愉悦，并真正思考这一点，并且不要害怕在，你知道，对你有意义的地方花钱，
and then avoid spending it because other people are because you feel like you should have it or, you know, because it's on sale. Like you're just a just a happier person overall. And I do try to shop like that. But I don't think I got there without a few mistakes along the way for sure. Yeah, I think we all do. We all make some bad, bad spending choices. But I think it's helpful. Amy, you're bringing a lot of information to listeners, too, about things they can look for in their own shopping behaviors to help make them wiser consumers. And I think that's really important. So when dear knowledge you've gained, you're helping others become just more mindful of what they're spending, why they're spending. I think that that does help everyone overall. Yeah. Yeah.
然后避免因为别人在花钱，或者因为你觉得你应该拥有它，或者，你知道，因为它在打折而花钱。就像你只是一个，只是一个更快乐的人。我确实尝试那样购物。但我认为如果没有一路上犯几个错误，我肯定不会达到那个地步。是的，我想我们都会。我们都会做出一些糟糕的、糟糕的消费选择。但我认为这很有帮助。艾米，你也为听众带来了很多关于他们可以在自己的购物行为中寻找什么的信息，以帮助他们成为更明智的消费者。我认为这真的很重要。所以当你获得的知识，你正在帮助其他人变得更加关注他们正在花什么，为什么花钱。我认为这确实在整体上帮助了每个人。是的。是的。
Thank you. I hope so. I enjoy doing it a lot. I really love my, I love my research and I love my work. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Yarrow. This has been a really, really fascinating conversation, a lot of great tips for people about how to spend more mindfully and be aware of their behaviors in stores and maybe to not get stuck stuck in by those samples at Costco. I'll try to remember that next time I'm there. Okay. It's been a pleasure. Thank you for having me. Before we go, we just want to remind you that we love to hear from you. You can email me your comments and ideas to K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A at APA.org. Also, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes.
谢谢。我希望如此。我非常喜欢做这件事。我真的很爱我的，我爱我的研究，我爱我的工作。非常感谢你加入我们，亚罗博士。这是一次非常、非常迷人的谈话，为人们提供了很多关于如何更理智地消费以及在商店里意识到自己的行为的绝佳建议，也许不要被Costco的那些样品所困住。下次我去那里时，我会尽量记住这一点。好的。这是我的荣幸。谢谢你邀请我。在我们离开之前，我们只想提醒你，我们喜欢收到你的来信。你可以通过电子邮件将你的评论和想法发送给我，地址是K-Luna@APA.org。那是K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。此外，请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分。
We'd really appreciate it. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other podcasts such as APA journals dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all of our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also visit speakingof psychology.org to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们将不胜感激。《心理学谈话》是APA播客网络的一部分，该网络包括其他播客，如关于新心理学研究的《APA期刊对话》和关于心理学实践的《进度记录》。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问speakingofpsychology.org收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。